Eso en grupos piramidales.
Bueno, muchachos, como les dije conmigo, o se enamoran mucho de esa profesión,
o tienen la toda ya, ¿por qué?
Esa para mí es la mejor profesión del mundo.
Para mí esa es, por algo lo enseñamos,
lo enseñamos y no solamente lo enseñamos, sino que también
lo operamos, practicamos, son todos los que hacemos parte de TFT,
operamos todas las mañanas.
A mí me gusta mucho operar la bolsa europea a las 2 de la mañana
y mi trade empieza desde las 2 de la mañana.
Para mí es la mejor profesión del mundo porque tengo mucho tiempo.
O sea, esa profesión me deja hacer muchas cosas en mi día a día,
encargarme de muchas cosas al mismo tiempo.
porque usted puede generar ingresos en dólares si está en un país como Colombia.
la moneda es cuatro veces más de lo que usted gasta,
entonces, es mucho mejor, es muy bueno.
Pero, pues, también tenemos que entender que eso es un proceso,
es un proceso que ustedes están empezando y que es un proceso que,
como tal y como todos, se tienen que respetar.
El hecho de que ya sepan operar, de que ya aprendan ustedes a operar.
Yo les, me gusta decirles que esto, y es que lo mejor que puedan,
que puede pasar en sus operaciones es que empiecen perdiendo.
¿Por qué? Porque si ustedes empiezan con una racha ganadora,
créanme que es lo, una de las cosas que para mí,
que para mi pensar es de las peores cosas que le pueden pasar a un trader.
¿Por qué? Porque se llena mucho de confianza
y siente que cogió el cielo con las manos y esto.
Ese negocio es de usted nivelar mucho sus emociones,
de tratar de manejarlas muy bien al momento de operar.
De todo eso vamos a hablar esta semana, de las zonas emocionales.
Listo, hoy vamos a ver estructura de mercado.
Les voy a compartir pantalla para que empecemos.
En el momento que quieran hacer una pausa,
una pausa en la conversación, en la charla, en el entrenamiento,
lo hacen.
Yo entiendo que es un tema nuevo que van a ver.
Y yo les puedo hacer la aclaración en el momento que sea.
Listo, ¿entendido?
Entendido, Cristian, muchas gracias.
Sí, señor. Muchas gracias.
Bueno, muchachos.
Vamos a empezar.
Estructura de mercado.
Ahora yo voy a identificar una estructura del mercado.
La estructura del mercado para nosotros en agotamientos
depende del primer paso.
¿Cuál es el primer paso?
Ya lo vamos a ver acá.
Debemos de identificar un módulo de arranque.
Para operar en la estructura del mercado.
Un módulo de arranque.
¿Qué es el módulo de arranque?
El módulo de arranque es el precio más bajo de un mercado alcista
desde donde se impulsa el mercado.
Desde donde se impulsa dicho mercado.
Entonces, el módulo de arranque es el precio más bajo de un mercado alcista.
Desde donde se impulsa el mercado.
¿Cómo así?
Listo.
A mí me gusta esta herramienta porque yo le llamo alta plastilina.
Donde yo les voy a enseñar minuiciosamente y está diseñado así para que ustedes lo puedan entender mucho mejor.
Y si no lo entienden, me preguntan y con mucho gusto yo les vuelvo y les repito.
Las veces que sea, muchachos.
Las veces que sea.
¿Oye?
Entonces, miren.
Vemos un mercado, por ejemplo.
Vamos a ver un mercado acá.
Que viene así, bajando.
¿Cierto?
Y yo, el módulo de arranque.
Dice que es el precio más bajo.
Vamos a hablar hoy de un mercado alcista.
Que es el precio más bajo desde donde se impulsa el mercado.
Entonces, ¿en qué temporalidad voy a sacar yo mi módulo de arranque?
En cinco minutos.
Aquí lo que ya lo hacemos acá y nos vamos con la plataforma.
¿Cómo así?
Sí, yo me voy a ir para la temporalidad de cinco minutos y voy a identificar mi módulo de arranque.
Entonces, ¿cómo así que vamos a identificar mi módulo de arranque?
Vemos un mercado así, bajando.
Y yo necesito saber cuál es el precio más bajo desde donde se me está impulsando un mercado.
Entonces, yo voy a mirar el precio más bajo.
Siempre voy a mirar la parte de abajo del mercado.
Sabemos que en una tendencia, esta es la parte de arriba y esta es la parte de abajo.
Listo.
¿Cuál es el precio más bajo desde donde se me está impulsando el mercado?
Entonces, yo voy a mirar hacia atrás en cinco minutos.
Este no, este es no porque tengo un precio más bajo.
Este es no porque tengo un precio más bajo.
Entonces, voy hacia atrás, miren, este es, voy a trazar una línea para saber si este es el precio más bajo del mercado.
Y efectivamente, este es mi módulo de arranque.
El precio más bajo desde donde se impulsa este mercado con todos estos movimientos.
Listo.
Ahora, después de que identifiquemos ese módulo de arranque, vamos a ver la estructura del mercado.
Esa estructura nace desde un ABC.
La estructura nace desde un ABC.
El ABC es el primer movimiento del mercado final.
Cualquier mercado que usted quiera operar.
Cualquier mercado regulado.
Los futuros de Nasdaq, futuros de Russell, el petróleo, oro, todos los mercados que usted quiera operar, va a tener un módulo de arranque.
Y después de que identifiquemos este módulo de arranque, que lo vamos a ver acá, ya dijimos que este es el módulo de arranque, vamos a cazar ese primer movimiento que nos da el mercado.
¿Cómo hace que el primer movimiento?
Sí.
Desde ese precio, se está impulsando el mercado.
Ese primer movimiento del mercado debe tener un retroceso.
Ese movimiento, yo ya les voy a explicar de qué se trata este movimiento.
Cuando el próximo movimiento me haga este mismo, me deja el primer movimiento del mercado que lo llamamos ABC.
De este ABC puede partir todo.
Un ABC, desde ese ABC nace todo lo que usted quiera, una tendencia entera.
¿Listo?
Entonces, primer movimiento del mercado, el módulo de arranque, sigue, de ese movimiento del módulo de arranque, sigue con un ABC.
Ya lo vamos a ver en el mercado real.
Este es de donde nace cualquier movimiento, tendencia, onda, el ABC.
Esto es para que lo podamos entender.
Pero, los mercados financieros, ustedes ya lo pueden ver en lo que les ha enseñado Jenny y lo que les ha enseñado Daniel, se mueven de una manera muy diferente.
Ellos no van a ser toda la vida, van a ser alcistas, o todo un día, por mucho que noticia positiva, van a ser alcistas, o toda la vida van a ser un mercado bajista, ¿no?
No toda la vida no va a ser un mercado, no va a tener este momento, o todo un día, o todo un mes.
Bueno, todo un día de pronto sí.
Pero no toda una semana, ni todo un mes, ni todo un año.
Ya sabemos que, ya lo han visto, en los días anteriores, que los mercados financieros se mueven por medio de ondas, ¿cierto?
Esas ondas tienen, ondas hacia arriba, ondas hacia abajo, vuelve a ser ondas hacia arriba, y vuelve a ser ondas hacia abajo.
Esas ondas tienen un nombre, el nombre del creador de las ondas, que se llama, ondas de helio.
¿Listo?
Entonces miren que, estas ondas de helio, que tienen, módulos de arranque, módulos de arranque, módulos de arranque, y módulos de arranque.
Y eso es lo que estamos hablando todavía en 5 minutos.
O sea, no nos hemos parado para otra temporalidad, temporalidad de 5 minutos.
¿Cómo así?
Siga, este impulso, lo generó, se generó desde este movimiento, desde este precio.
Este otro impulso hacia abajo, se generó desde este otro precio.
Este es un impulso hacia arriba, se generó desde este precio, y este hacia abajo, desde este precio.
Ahora, esas ondas,
esas ondas tienen unos nombres.
Por ejemplo, este ABC es una onda,
pero las más populares es la onda con 5 movimientos o fallo de quinta.
¿Cómo así que 5 movimientos o fallo de quinta?
Ahora, después del ABC, el próximo movimiento que me haga,
que sea otro retroceso similar a este,
pero que me respete la estructura que se está formando.
Acá tenemos un ABC, un movimiento alcista.
Y para yo determinar este movimiento como un fallo de quinta,
me voy a hacer este retroceso,
y a la vez, el próximo movimiento, me voy a dejar otro impulso.
Y esto lo vamos a tener en cuenta como un fallo de quinta.
Ya el ABC, ya deja de ser un ABC,
porque el movimiento que me hizo,
tuvo continuidad a una onda con 5 movimientos.
Y este ya sería el paso 1,
el paso 2 hacia abajo,
el paso 3,
el paso 4,
y el paso 5,
ese último impulso.
De la misma manera, muchachos,
este fallo de quinta,
puede tener otro movimiento más.
¿Cómo así?
Sí.
El próximo movimiento que tenga,
así como este cuarto y este segundo,
puede que tenga el impulso que tenga,
siempre y cuando me respete estructura.
¿Cómo así que me respete estructura?
Sí, que me respete esos movimientos que me dejó anteriores,
desde donde se impulsó.
Entonces, si me hace ese movimiento,
respetando estructura,
y el próximo vuelve sin pulso,
y me deja este impulso significativo,
este fallo de quinta,
se nos convierte en un fallo de séptima,
con 7 movimientos.
Acá está el sexto,
y acá el séptimo.
¿Listo?
Estos son,
lo que ustedes pueden ver en YouTube,
lo que ustedes pueden investigar,
en un canal de trading,
le van a enseñar,
solamente hasta este movimiento,
el fallo de quinta.
Nosotros en el transcurso del tiempo,
vimos que el mercado tenía otra continuidad,
y nos daba un movimiento asista,
retroceso y otro movimiento asista,
para un fallo de séptima.
Miren que,
lo que les dije al principio,
nació desde una B6,
pero como tuvo,
una continuidad de existe,
y respetó la estructura del mercado,
nos dejó un fallo de quinta.
Ese fallo de quinta,
también respetó la estructura,
y tuvo la continuidad,
del mercado.
Un movimiento asista,
como estos,
siempre,
lo vamos a marcar,
por la parte de abajo.
¿Por qué?
Porque ustedes,
sin saber,
qué va a ser el mercado,
acá y acá,
va a unir,
el módulo de arranque,
con el primer mínimo,
que nos dejó,
que es este,
cuando termine el paso 2.
Y usted puede trazar una línea,
como referencia,
y miren que,
sin saber,
qué va a ser acá y acá,
el mercado va a respetar,
este movimiento,
y este movimiento.
Cuando su mercado asista.
Entonces,
a ese mercado asista,
la parte de abajo,
le vamos a llamar,
los mínimos,
los mínimos de un mercado asista,
la parte de arriba,
lo vamos a llamar,
los máximos,
pero esta,
no es tan necesario trazar.
Solamente,
en un mercado asista,
solamente la parte de abajo.
¿Alguien sabe,
por qué es importante,
marcar esta línea,
de tendencia,
que se le llama,
por la parte de abajo?
¿O a alguien se le ocurre algo?
¿Cómo?
Porque así,
podemos identificar,
que es la tendencia alcista.
Exacto.
Se puede identificar,
la tendencia alcista,
porque respeta,
los movimientos anteriores,
la estructura anterior.
Miren que,
si yo,
sin yo saber,
y ahora lo vamos a ver,
que acá,
iba a ser esto,
y eso,
yo voy a coger,
desde el módulo de arranque,
y el primer mínimo,
y lo voy a aplazar.
Y vamos a esperar,
que haga,
que cumpla con,
efectividad con,
el fallo del quinto,
y el fallo del séptimo.
Listo.
¿Cómo van a estar ahí,
muchachos?
Bien,
bien,
entendido.
Listo.
Igual,
en el momento,
que ustedes quieran,
pausarlo,
explicamos de nuevo,
no tengo problema.
Yo lo que necesito,
es que,
en este curso intensivo,
ustedes,
tengan un aprendizaje,
relámpago,
pero que empiecen,
un proceso,
con sus carreras,
como trader,
para que manejen,
una consistencia,
a largo plazo.
Michael,
la próxima semana,
les va a enseñar,
todo lo que relacionamos,
a cuentas de fondeo,
cómo operamos nosotros,
con qué broker operamos,
cómo pueden acceder ustedes,
a estas cuentas de fondeo,
que ahora,
como estar,
estar a muy,
muy buen precio,
ya no hay necesidad,
de arriesgar el capital,
de cada uno de ustedes,
sino que pueden empezar,
con cuentas de fondeo,
para que empiecen,
paulatinamente.
Ya después,
ustedes pueden,
coger un capital,
después de que tengan,
el conocimiento,
y lo,
como la palabra,
lo se llama,
empiezan a capitalizarlo,
para que vayan a crecer.
Un valor,
de un ejemplo,
de mil,
y lo conviertan,
en cinco mil,
y de esos cinco mil,
en diez mil,
y así,
políticamente.
Listo.
Ahora,
vámonos para el mercado,
vámonos para el mercado financiero.
¿Qué vamos a ver,
en el mercado financiero,
muchachos?
¿En qué temporalidad,
les dije yo,
que,
que vamos a sacar,
ese módulo de arranque?
Sí.
Cinco minutos.
Exactamente,
en cinco minutos.
Entonces,
¿yo qué necesito?
Miren,
esto es,
vamos a ver,
hoy vamos a ver,
siempre,
siempre vamos a ver,
el mercado que cerró.
O sea,
hoy vemos el mercado de hoy.
Entonces,
cinco minutos,
esto es cinco minutos,
yo necesito identificar un módulo de arranque,
pero,
como estamos viendo un módulo de arranque,
ahí exista,
recuerden que,
el módulo de arranque exista,
es el precio,
más bajo,
del mercado.
Entonces,
acá yo tengo un precio,
señor.
Usted estaba proyectando.
Está proyectando,
el mercado.
Sí,
no,
no se ve.
No,
te veo a ti no más.
Ok,
déjame mirar qué paso.
Ahí ya.
Sí,
sí,
ya veo,
ya veo la pantalla,
ya veo el mercado.
Ok.
Entonces,
miren,
yo qué necesito acá,
estamos en cinco minutos.
Yo,
día juicioso,
cuando ustedes se vayan a sentar a operar,
lo primero que vamos a hacer,
es sacar soportes y resistencias,
como les enseñó,
de Jenny y Daniel,
de temporalidad alta,
hacia atrás.
Listo.
Entonces,
¿qué tenemos acá?
Acá tenemos,
un número cerrado,
una resistencia muy interesante,
que la podemos trazar de acá,
de toda esta mecha,
16,000.
Acá tenemos otra resistencia muy pegada,
y acá tenemos en la parte de abajo un soporte.
¿Por qué un soporte?
Porque acá viene y testió,
testió, testió, testió,
ya con tres toques,
es un soporte muy interesante,
en 240.
Acá también tenemos,
en este precio,
15,500,
un soporte,
vámonos para 60 minutos,
y en 60 minutos vamos a corroborar estas,
podemos colocar esta un poquito más arriba,
en una hora,
entonces miren que,
esto lo podemos testar acá,
esta está muy interesante,
y saben,
ustedes ya saben por qué marcar este soporte,
es esta resistencia,
¿cierto?
¿Ya saben cómo hacerlo?
¿O alguien tiene dudas?
¿Todos saben?
Sí, sí,
si no se explicaron.
Ok.
Dice,
entonces miren que 60 ya tenemos,
un soporte,
y dos resistencias,
vamos para 30,
intentamos a corroborar,
que si sean esos precios,
donde están rebotando el mercado,
se lo podemos poner,
un poquito más abajo,
a 15 minutos,
en 15 minutos,
también me gusta ver,
los patrones de vela,
y vamos a mirar,
que esa resistencia,
por ejemplo,
si sea exactamente,
esa la que necesitemos,
abajo el soporte,
que si esté pegando,
los mismos precios,
y ya por ejemplo,
nos vamos para 5 minutos,
ya hemos corroborado,
en varias temporalidades,
y acá en 5 minutos,
es la temporalidad,
donde vamos a sacar,
nuestro módulo de arranque,
entonces,
recuerden esto muchachos,
la estructura de mercado,
cuando vamos a hablar de un mercado alcista,
es esto,
esta es la estructura del mercado,
un mercado alcista,
cuál es el módulo de arranque,
el precio más bajo,
desde donde se impulsa,
este mercado,
en este caso,
sería este,
el módulo de arranque,
ahora,
vamos a hacerlo,
vamos a sacarlo acá,
en 5 minutos,
siempre,
lo primero que voy a ir,
después de que saque,
los soportes y las resistencias,
me quedo en 5 minutos,
y en 5 minutos,
voy a identificar,
módulo de arranque,
entonces,
empezamos por este,
este puede ser mi módulo de arranque,
no,
porque acá ya hay un movimiento,
diferente,
pero vamos a enfocarnos,
hoy,
en el módulo de arranque,
del sistema,
entonces,
yo que voy a hacer,
voy a tener para atrás,
en 5 minutos,
voy a buscar,
un precio,
desde donde se ha impulsado,
el mercado,
acá tengo un precio,
donde vino,
retesteó,
recuerden que,
es esto que les digo,
ven que desde acá,
se está impulsando,
entonces,
yo que voy a decir,
este mismo módulo de arranque,
no,
porque hay un precio,
más abajo,
véanlo acá,
este mismo módulo de arranque,
o sea,
hay uno más abajo,
entonces,
este no es,
que necesito mirar,
si hay un precio,
más abajo,
el módulo de arranque,
lo vamos a sacar,
teniendo en cuenta,
la sesión,
donde abre la sesión asiática,
europea,
que es,
abre a las 5 de la tarde,
la asiática,
abre a la europea,
a las 2 de la mañana,
del mismo día,
entonces,
miren que nosotros,
acá lo señalamos,
desde la apertura,
asiática europea,
porque yo no voy a tener en cuenta,
lo que pasó el día anterior,
en la sesión americana,
entonces,
acá,
a la 1 de la mañana,
tengo,
un módulo de arranque,
donde se me está impulsando,
todo este mercado,
cierto,
vamos a marcarlo,
miren,
el máximo,
mínimo,
máximo,
muy notorio,
muy hasta arriba,
me deja ese último máximo,
y que paso acá,
esta estructura,
intentó girar,
porque nos hizo,
otra onda,
en una onda,
miren,
miren que los movimientos,
de esa onda,
ya eran diferentes,
a los movimientos,
de esa onda,
esta es una onda bajista,
con 1,
y 7 movimientos,
ahora,
vamos a contar,
es 1,
esta yo la contaría,
así,
recuerde que la estructura,
del mercado,
está formada,
por máximos,
y por mínimos,
podemos contar acá,
por máximos,
y por mínimos,
tenemos,
y se marca,
por la parte,
de abajo,
de este mercado,
recuerden que,
un mercado bajista,
se marca,
por la parte,
de abajo,
de todos los mínimos,
donde nos pegaron,
donde nos tocó los mínimos,
entonces,
miren que yo voy a coger,
desde el módulo de arranque,
que empezó prácticamente,
a acá,
y voy a juntarla,
con este precio,
así,
esa sería,
una línea de tendencia,
macro,
en términos,
que aunque tuvo,
otra onda bajista,
ese precio,
lo vino y lo tocó,
como lo tocó acá,
¿cómo vamos muchachos,
cómo van hasta ahora,
alguna duda,
alguna pregunta,
disculpe,
Cristian,
entonces,
el,
el módulo de arranque,
lo vemos,
desde qué hora,
siempre,
desde que arranca el mercado,
o un poco antes,
el módulo de arranque,
lo vamos a poder,
a ver,
desde cualquier hora,
¿por qué?
Porque miren,
aunque la tendencia macro,
es una tendencia,
alcista,
en que desde acá,
se está impulsando,
desde ese precio,
que tenemos acá abajo,
está impulsando el mercado,
pero,
anteriormente,
también había,
un movimiento,
pero solamente,
lo vamos a tener en cuenta,
desde la apertura,
asiática,
miren,
y esto,
es otra onda,
esto es un módulo de arranque,
bajista,
con esta onda bajista,
¿por qué?
porque me genera,
movimientos,
bajistas,
este es un módulo,
de arranque,
así está,
porque me genera,
un movimiento,
alcista,
y adivine que,
aunque tengamos,
un impulso,
muy significativo,
este,
es un movimiento,
bajista,
dentro de un,
dentro de una onda,
alcista,
entonces,
como les dije,
ahora,
el mercado,
se mueve por ondas,
esto es una onda,
y esto es una onda,
esto es un módulo de arranque,
bajista,
un módulo de arranque,
alcista,
y un módulo de arranque,
bajista,
lo que pasa,
es que,
tenemos que entender,
esta parte,
cien por ciento,
para poder pasar,
a la otra parte,
que es el momento,
en el que vamos a entrar,
el momento,
como es la entrada,
del mercado,
pero,
yo,
les debo dejar,
super,
super claro,
todo esto,
el módulo de arranque,
para que ustedes puedan entender,
cómo vamos a entrar,
listo,
miremos,
miremos una cosa muchachos,
y es que,
el mercado,
este precio,
que tenemos acá,
es un precio,
de una,
temporalidad alta,
este que les estoy marcando,
en el rectángulo,
donde en una temporalidad alta,
esto es una resistencia,
eso es una resistencia,
entonces,
que quiere decir eso,
que el mercado,
en una temporalidad alta,
desde acá,
vendieron,
que quiere decir eso,
que para yo poder entrar,
en una compra,
el mercado,
me tiene que quedar,
por encima,
de este precio,
para que esa resistencia,
que tengo,
tenemos,
en una temporalidad alta,
me sirva,
de soporte,
ya no va a ser,
una resistencia,
como lo hizo acá,
sino que,
lo vamos a tomar,
como soporte,
listo,
entonces,
en este orden de ideas,
que podemos sacar,
que,
desde la apertura asiática,
y hasta el momento,
que ya,
vamos a abrir,
la apertura americana,
tenemos,
un módulo de arranque,
bajista,
ese módulo de arranque,
tuvo,
un impulso,
y nos generó,
un módulo de arranque,
a la,
una de la mañana,
ese impulso,
de cista,
tuvo,
movimientos bajistas,
una onda bajista,
con movimientos bajistas,
y tuvo,
un módulo de arranque,
a las cinco,
de la mañana,
con todos estos movimientos,
ahora,
estamos a,
un minuto,
aproximadamente,
de que,
abramos la bolsa,
en Nueva York,
y,
vamos a,
identificar,
como,
vamos a entrar,
en el mercado,
después de que nos deja,
este movimiento,
listo,
como van hasta ahora,
muchachos,
y,
estas,
estoy siendo claro,
si,
muy claro,
señor,
ok,
eso muchachos,
si señor,
vamos a continuar,
entonces,
recuerden esto,
esto es muy importante,
miren,
este precio,
que marcamos acá,
lo sacamos,
en la temporalidad alta,
ya estamos en cinco minutos,
la temporalidad,
donde vamos a sacar,
el módulo de arranque,
y donde,
esta,
este precio,
nos va a servir,
de soporte,
si lo rompe,
o si lo respeta,
lo ha respetado,
y ya vamos a tener,
la apertura americana,
entonces,
nos hace esto,
y nos respeta,
este precio,
es para meterle,
un corto,
o una venta,
al mercado,
listo,
vamos a ver,
que pasa,
acá vamos a abrir,
ya la apertura,
en Nueva York,
vamos a hacer,
la apertura,
en Nueva York,
para que,
analicemos entre todos,
que puede pasar,
esta es la apertura,
en Nueva York,
una apertura,
muy volátil,
la volatilidad,
que hace,
esta vela,
y es porque,
se unen,
todas las bolsas,
en una sola,
liberándola,
la bolsa de Nueva York,
es por eso,
que tenemos,
esa volatilidad,
y por eso,
el tamaño,
de las velas,
es totalmente diferente,
a los de la bolsa,
europea,
miren chicos,
algo muy importante,
que pues,
que esta paso hoy,
y algo muy importante,
que ustedes van a poder ver,
esta estructura de mercado,
y yo necesito,
que ustedes esto,
se les quede muy grabado,
miren,
esta estructura de mercado,
yo voy a bloquear,
esta,
para que no se me,
borre,
y borre las demás,
y esta,
para que me,
para hacerme entender,
muy bien,
lo que les quiero hacer entender,
listo,
dijimos,
que este,
era el módulo de arranque,
y que el módulo de arranque,
se,
tenía en cuenta,
la parte de abajo,
y que llegó,
hasta un precio,
que,
el mercado,
posiblemente,
haya girado,
y el,
y la,
y los movimientos,
bajistas,
no se tienen en cuenta,
por debajo,
sino que se tienen en cuenta,
por encima,
ya saben,
por qué,
con esta,
con esta línea,
por qué debemos,
de trazar esa línea,
y para qué,
recuerden,
que,
la estructura de mercado,
se,
se conforma,
por estos máximos,
y estos mínimos,
pero no solamente,
por esos máximos,
y por esos mínimos,
sino,
cuando,
el próximo movimiento,
respeta,
el movimiento anterior,
es muy importante,
yo trazar,
esta línea de tendencia,
que la marco,
desde este precio,
desde el módulo de arranque,
con el primer mínimo,
miren,
que si yo la trazo,
desde acá,
ella me va a dar,
todos estos movimientos,
que muy probable,
me lo está,
respetando ahí,
cierto,
pero,
que pasa,
cuando,
esa estructura,
se rompió,
cuando,
totalmente,
diferente,
a los,
que me venía,
haciendo acá,
mira que,
el máximo,
me dejó,
un máximo acá,
pero acá,
ya no me está dejando,
un alto más alto,
sino que,
un alto más bajo,
un alto,
más bajo,
ya no tienen fuerza,
ya los que están comprando acá,
los que compraron,
en este módulo de arranque,
vendieron acá,
y es lo que estamos viendo,
en este momento,
lo que pasó acá,
entonces,
miren que tenemos,
un alto más alto,
pero esos máximos,
y esos mínimos,
rompieron la estructura,
acá tenemos ya,
un alto más bajo,
pero,
muy cerquita,
a la apertura,
de Nueva York,
entonces,
esa estructura,
que se está formando ahí,
ya la apertura,
de Nueva York,
la rompió,
y no solamente,
sino que rompió,
también,
esa resistencia,
para nosotros,
era muy importante,
porque era,
en la temporalidad,
alta,
desde los 40,
hacia atrás,
listo,
ahora,
cómo,
vamos a buscar,
una entrada,
ya teniendo en cuenta,
que rompimos estructura,
y que,
para nosotros,
ya ese rompimiento,
ese impulso,
es el paso número uno,
para buscar,
un agotamiento,
¿qué son agotamientos?
los agotamientos son,
estos engaños,
o esos movimientos,
que nos hacen,
vemos,
que el mercado,
está siendo,
alcista,
acá,
pero,
en este precio,
hace un retroceso,
ese retroceso,
para nosotros,
es,
la teoría,
es que es un retroceso,
cierto,
pero,
¿qué significa?
Este movimiento,
lo generó,
la entidad,
el fondo de inversiones,
o el banco,
que está comprando,
estas posiciones,
en este precio,
de esa misma manera,
ese trader,
que está moviendo,
el mercado institucional,
necesita,
ir por liquidez,
esa idea,
por liquidez,
o sea,
necesita ir por platica,
esa idea,
por platica,
lo vemos,
en este movimiento,
están haciendo,
creer algunos traders,
que el mercado,
va a bajar,
lo que están haciendo,
realmente,
es bajar,
por liquidez,
y acá,
los ponen a salida,
todos por stop,
todos salen por stop,
los que vendieron,
en este precio,
es por esas,
de las razones,
que nosotros,
no operamos,
con volumen,
no necesitamos,
el volumen,
para nada,
mire que volumen,
acá lo tenemos,
nosotros abajo,
no lo necesitamos,
para nada,
porque solamente,
operamos,
con la estructura,
del mercado,
si ya tenemos,
identificado,
este movimiento,
vamos a esperar,
que se genere,
este movimiento,
pero,
que me respete,
el que identificamos,
como modelo de arranque,
ya me van entendiendo,
más o menos,
a donde voy,
ya tenemos,
un impulso,
que rompió,
estructura bajista,
pero nosotros,
en ese impulso,
no entramos,
para nosotros,
este es el paso,
número uno,
para entrar,
en agotamientos,
el impulso,
existe,
que necesitamos,
para entrar,
después de que tenemos,
la confirmación,
del paso número uno,
que es el impulso,
que ven,
y haga el retroceso,
pero que me respete,
este precio,
que es el precio,
desde donde se impulsó,
el mercado,
porque,
porque ustedes también,
van a ver mucho esto,
que impulsa,
pero de la misma manera,
el mercado,
va a hacer esto,
y les va a llegar,
hasta el mismo precio,
desde donde se impulsó,
el mercado,
por esa razón,
nosotros,
que vamos a hacer,
después de que tengamos,
ese impulso,
ya identificado,
vamos a esperar,
que ellos bajen,
por liquidez,
cuando yo le hablo,
de ellos,
es el fondo de inversiones,
que mueve el mercado financiero,
los bancos,
o los grandes,
primeros institucionales,
que trabajan,
para hechas entidades,
ya tengo,
el primer impulso,
que estructuralmente,
vamos a pararlo por acá,
para irnos otra vez,
para la gráfica,
de alta plastilina,
es este,
en un mercado alcista,
pero yo necesito,
que ese impulso,
me genere,
el próximo movimiento,
y que ese movimiento,
sea un retroceso,
que este movimiento,
pero que me respete,
el precio,
desde donde se impulsó,
el mercado,
que es este,
para yo identificarlo,
como un retroceso,
como lo vamos a identificar,
ya les voy a decir,
entonces acá,
ya estamos en cinco minutos,
ya identificamos,
ese módulo de arranque,
ahora,
ya teniendo en cuenta,
que,
ya tenemos,
un nuevo módulo de arranque,
que rompió esa estructura,
me voy para un minuto,
¿qué vamos a hacer en un minuto?
vamos a esperar,
que el próximo movimiento,
que sea un retroceso,
en cinco minutos,
y en un minuto,
pero que me respete,
estructura,
¿cómo así que me respete estructura?
si,
ya tenemos todo este impulso,
entonces,
vamos a esperar,
que se genere,
ese movimiento,
y lo vamos a perseguir,
con una línea,
que llamamos,
nosotros,
la línea de,
agotamiento,
es lo que se frenó,
¿qué vamos a hacer en un minuto?
¿qué necesito?
¿que ese impulso en el cual incitaron a comprar bajen por liquidez?
nosotros esa bajada por liquidez la vamos a identificar con velas rojas
cuando estamos en un mercado alcista velas rojas
y vamos a trazar esas velas rojas por la parte de arriba con esta lineecita
esperando que, esperando que tenga un rompimiento de estructura
¿cómo así?
listo, que me salga una vela y que esa vela interrumpa este movimiento bajista
pero que aún así me siga respetando este módulo de arranque
entonces yo voy a perseguir ese retroceso
y cuando me salga una vela que me rompa esta línea de agotamiento
vamos a colocar la posición
ahora
algo muy importante que yo siempre digo en este punto es
y siempre lo voy a decir
y es que para mí no es solamente muy importante colocar la posición
si no saber colocar el stop
¿dónde voy a colocar el stop?
por ejemplo
en este caso
yo me voy para lápiz
y el lápiz me voy para risk reward
yo necesito que me dé un stop acorde a mi cuenta
un stop que no sobrepase el valor de mi cuenta
entonces
yo lo cojo acá
y lo voy a colocar
lo voy a buscar un último rebote
acá por ejemplo tenemos este último rebote
donde puede ser válido un stop
o por debajo
de esta resistencia
sería mucho más válido
que el mercado siga bajando
sigan bajando por liquidez
pero
que me respete
o este último rebote
para colocar
mi stop
o esa resistencia
mucho mejor
entonces cuando vamos a buscar una entrada en agotamientos
cuando la vela me quede por encima de esta línea
pero miren que también hay que tener en cuenta
ese stop
acá pasó algo muy particular
y es que miren la mecha
que quedó
esta mecha
yo la voy a tener en cuenta
con mi línea de agotamiento
entonces voy a ampliar
mi agotamiento
y voy a esperar sencillamente
que el mercado
haga lo que yo
sea que va a hacer
o sea que yo
en ese momento
que estoy esperando
que me haga un rompimiento
de una
línea de agotamiento
espero que me respete
estructura de mercado
vamos a ver
miren por ejemplo
ese agotamiento
yo necesito que
la vela me quede por encima
de esta línea
de agotamiento
si es así
si me queda
a este le faltan
¿cuánto?
10, 7
vamos acá
pongo mi stop
en este precio
y pongo mi profit
esto sería
irnos
en un
1 a 1
muchachos
¿cómo van?
preguntar hasta ahora
dudas
inquietudes
no señor
hasta el momento
muy bien
oh claro
sí señor
no
bueno
continuemos
si no tienen
preguntas
yo considero
que todo está
muy claro
cristian
¿cómo consideran
ustedes esta operación?
yo los quiero
escuchar
están muy callados
¿cómo consideran
ustedes que salió
esta operación?
le hago una consulta
por ejemplo
entonces
ahí se analizó
que fue
la línea de agotamiento
y respetó
la estructura
que viene
¿qué ven ustedes ahí?
cuéntenme
¿qué ven?
en lo que ya han aprendido
lo que ustedes quieran
tranquilos
Cristian
¿me escuchan?
primero que no lo estoy
escuchando
muchachos
el tema es mío
ahora sí
¿quién está hablando?
¿ahí me escucha?
sí ahí sí
ah bueno
Cristian le preguntaba
por ejemplo
ahí en esa entrada
se analizó
entonces
lo de la línea
de agotamiento
que respete
la estructura
con lo del
módulo de arranque
¿cierto?
que empezó
en la tendencia
bajista
cuando
entonces
toma la determinación
de entrar
es porque
la vela
rompió
totalmente
la línea
de agotamiento
¿cierto?
exacto
pero entonces
ahí no
no tenemos en cuenta
ningún patrón
de velas
por ejemplo
de lo que nos han enseñado
anteriormente
solamente
que haya
pasado la línea
de agotamiento
exactamente
lo que sí
vamos a tener
en cuenta
acá
es que
lo mismo
que usted
entró
en un minuto
o sea
miren
donde yo le marqué
acá
este circulito
que en cinco minutos
también
esté a favor
la vela
o sea
vamos a entrar
en una vela
así
o sea
en una vela
verde
en un minuto
pero que en cinco
también
que la estructura
del mercado
sea así
¿no?
o sea
que la entrada
se debe hacer
en temporalidad
de un minuto
preferiblemente
exacto
si la entrada
ustedes la pueden hacer
en uno
o en dos minutos
si quieren
también en dos
pero la confirmación
la
cinco minutos
la confirmación
de la estructura
la da cinco minutos
¿qué más tiene
preguntas
dudas
o por ejemplo
tiene opinión
sobre esa operación
que acabamos de hacer
o si todo está
muy claro
continuamos
yo miro por acá
seguimos
muchos
tienen todo
clarísimo
Cristian
si es claro
pero digamos
que yo todavía
no tengo
los argumentos
para poderle
explicar
la operación
no sé si de pronto
usted nos quisiera
dar luces
sí
a ver
como
¿qué creen ustedes
que acá
o sea
lo que yo les quiero
preguntar es
¿cómo ven ustedes
esta operación?
según lo que ustedes
han aprendido
de Daniel
y de Jenny
¿qué creen ustedes?
¿cómo la ven acá?
esta que acabamos
de hacer
yo vi en la entrada
que hubo
como un retesteo
¿cierto?
entonces ahí
se tomó la decisión
de entrar
por lo que yo vi
¿cierto?
sí
exactamente
bien
y es algo
que yo
les quería
traer acá
y mucho
o sea
hoy
ese mercado
muy
fue muy
ejemplar
fue muy maestro
¿por qué?
porque mire
acá por ejemplo
se nos dio
una entrada
en agotamiento
si ustedes van a ver
hacia atrás
ustedes pueden ver
agotamientos
como un berraco
miren por ejemplo
eso
se va a ver
acá un agotamiento
y cruzó
y entramos
para atrás
ustedes van a poder
ver muchas cosas
muchos agotamientos
pero
acá teníamos
algo
muy fuerte
por el cual
no podíamos
entrar
en este
agotamiento
aunque se nos
presentó
y por eso
soy muy enfático
en esto
yo quiero que ustedes
se graben muy bien
esto
miren
aunque se nos presentó
ese agotamiento
y un agotamiento
patentico
muy clarito
no era válido
entrar
en ese
agotamiento
por una razón
yo creo que
eso lo vieron
ustedes con Dani
alguien sabe
por cual razón
no no yo no me acuerdo
listo
no importa Jorge
tranquilo
miren
hay una
algo que
que hacemos
en premercado
y es
sentarnos
a trazar
estas linecitas
que yo
marqué
con rectángulos
que son
soportes
y resistencias
entonces
las marcamos
para qué
para saber
esto nos está
indicando
el mercado
anteriormente
que hizo
en una temporalidad
por ejemplo
esta que marcamos
es una resistencia
que marcamos
en 16.000
o sea
acá
de donde se está
devolviendo
ese mercado
qué quiere decir
eso
por muy bonito
que yo vea
este movimiento
que me está dando
el mercado
por muy bonito
que yo lo vea
acá
este rompimiento
con esta resistencia
acá
sería
o colocar
un profit
por debajo
de esa resistencia
pero lo más indicado
es esperar
o entrar
en un corto
ahí
donde llegó
a ese precio
porque ya el mercado
estaba en la parte
de arriba
o esperar
que el movimiento
sea totalmente
diferente
o sea
que sea eso
porque
no podemos
entrar
cerca
a una resistencia
de alta temporalidad
eso es
una ley
muchachos
eso es ley
de trader
si usted se dedicó
a
rayar
a marcar
en el premercado
es para
respetar
eso
como si
hay que respetar
eso
si respetar
esos precios
que marcamos
en premercado
como soportes
y como resistencias
si ya teníamos
una resistencia
acá
que nos sacamos
en premercado
se tiene
que respetar
entonces
tengo un agotamiento
acá muy clarísimo
si
pero se acercita
a una resistencia
y eso no es
entrada
para nosotros
¿entendido?
sí señor
¿cómo
cómo vamos a buscar
una entrada
cuando tenemos
una resistencia
de acá
tan cerquita
en agotamientos?
bueno
espérame
esto por acá
¿por qué agotamientos?
miren
porque
vamos a reconocer
un mercado
y el mercado
lo vamos a reconocer
cuando tenemos
impulsos
pero para nosotros
ese impulso
es el paso
número uno
para entrar
el paso
número dos
es cuando
el siguiente
movimiento
me haga
lo que nosotros
llamamos
retroceso
ese retroceso
nosotros vamos
a empezar
a ver
que tienen
unas velitas
como así
y se empiezan
a agotar
que ya no tienen
esta fuerza
y que ya se empieza
a agotar
¿qué vamos a hacer
nosotros?
lo vamos a trazar
con una línea
de agotamiento
por la parte
de arriba
esperando
que nos salga
esta vela
¿y qué vamos a hacer?
vamos a colocar
nuestra entrada
acá
y el stop
en el precio
que fue el último rebote
y esto sería
una estructura
de mercado
alcista
¿cómo hace que
una estructura
de mercado alcista
así?
esto es como si usted
cogiera una cauchera
y la jalara
hacia atrás
¿qué nos da
confirmación?
es impulso
que la cauchera
se va a impulsar
de la misma manera
hasta mejor
y esto
es coger
el paso
número
tres
el del ABC
de un mercado
alcista
que es el que más
nos interesa
a nosotros
coger
porque es el más
sustancioso
y lo podemos
decir así
listo
el paso número
tres
por ejemplo
después de un módulo
de arranque
si tenemos
este como el nuevo
módulo de arranque
uno
vamos a ver
en cinco minutos
uno
nos llegó
hasta la resistencia
dos
y acá
podríamos esperar
el paso
número tres
pero estamos
igual
de la misma manera
cerquita
a esa resistencia
que vamos
que tenemos
ahí pendientes
que sacamos
en una temporalidad alta
entonces
cuando tenemos
una resistencia
tan cerquita
lo que vamos
a hacer
es esperar
que ese mercado
rompa esa resistencia
se devuelva
y que ese techo
que nos estaba
ahorita
impidiendo
entrar
nos sirva
de piso
para colocar
una posición
y ya les voy a decir
cómo la vamos
a colocar
acá
¿qué necesitamos?
es una entrada
muy demorada
es un poquito
demorada la entrada
pero
si no le da
confirmación
a usted como trader
toca esperar
porque si usted
no vendió
acá
como que
vio confirmación
para venta
eso lo vamos
a ver mañana
esperamos
que ese impulso
y que ese impulso
nos rompa
ese precio
que nos dio
la confirmación
en agotamiento
o sea
que tenga
un retroceso
de velas continuas
para entrar
en un
agotamiento
al sistema
si yo no
entré acá
en venta
en esa resistencia
yo ya tengo
que esperar
ya tenemos
un impulso
que es este
vamos a esperar
que
haga lo suyo
que haga todo
ese movimiento
bajista
porque lo que
nosotros necesitamos
es que nos rompa
ese precio
entonces
¿cómo vamos a entrar?
vamos a esperar
que nos haga
un impulso
que ese impulso
nos haga
un retroceso
y que ese retroceso
sea de velas continuas
¿cómo así que
de velas continuas?
o sea
de velas rojas
de esta manera
para yo poder
trazar
mi línea
de agotamiento
por la parte de arriba
y buscar
un rompimiento
sobre ese precio
o sea
así
miren
lo que está pasando
acá
ya está llegando
a ese precio
de nuevo
que necesitamos
o que necesito
yo en este momento
que me genere
ese impulso
el retroceso
y que sea
un retroceso
de velas continuas
para yo poder
colocar
mi posición
pero cuando
me rompa
esta línea
vamos a ver
si lo hace
esta mechita
la tengo en cuenta
y ahora
¿qué necesito?
que ese rompimiento
me dé una entrada
sobre ese techo
que ahora me puede
servir de piso
algo muy importante
que yo tengo que
tener en cuenta
acá
y es que
¿dónde voy a colocar
mi stop?
si voy a colocar
una entrada
en este precio
el stop
lo voy a poner
en el último rebote
acá tengo un rebote
que es este
y acá abajo
tenemos un rebote
más cercano
que es
este abajo
entonces miren
que yo lo puedo
colocar
a más o menos
puedo calcular
cuánto puede ser
mi pérdida
y me dé
respeta
este retroceso
aproximadamente
80 dólares
por contrato
vamos a ver
debe romper
esta línea
ese retroceso
para poder
colocar nuestra posición
hasta que
no nos la rompa
no es entrada
para nosotros
vamos a ver
acá
si la rompe
bueno les digo
lo más importante
no es colocar
la posición
sino también
colocar
ese stop
en ese rebote
vamos a buscar
esos rebotes
acá en rebote
listo
esto nos puede servir
porque
acá el mercado
se impulsó
pero eso solamente
lo podemos colocar
cuando nos rompa
esta línea
de agotamiento
acá parece que
me voy a dar
confirmación
cuánto le falta
dos
y señor
vamos a colocar
el stop
por acá
y el profit
lo vamos a poner
por acá
eso es un agotamiento
un agotamiento
alcista
sobre un precio
que antes era
un techo
ahora nos va a servir
de piso
y vamos a ver
que nos da
ese entrar
en agotamiento
muy bien
lo importante
no es solamente
colocar
esa entrada
sino
el stop
es más importante
aún
porque ese es el que
nos va a proteger
esa posición
es un stop
donde yo hubiera tenido
un stop cortico
que hubiera pasado
acá
ya me hubiera sacado
entonces
por eso es que yo voy a buscar
un rebote
para un posible stop
y evitar que
vaya
por mi
me case
y continúe a favor
vamos a ver
miren todo el movimiento
que hace
es una entrada
muy demorada
porque ya
el mercado ya lleva
aproximadamente
dos horas de apertura
pero siempre
cuando yo tenga
el stop
bien puestecito
ahí en el rebote
no pasa
absolutamente nada
y pues obviamente
que se apalanquen
lo
lo normal
para sus cuentas
miren
muy bien
les repito
lo que les dije
al comienzo
lo
lo mejor
que les puede pasar
a ustedes
como trader
es que empiecen
perdiendo
que empiecen
regulando
esas emociones
al momento
de operar
que empiecen
ustedes
identificando
que sienten
al momento
de operar
pero no en demo
sino en cuenta real
es lo que
ustedes van a operar
más adelante
miren la estructura
que se está
formando
una estructura
alcista
donde los máximos
son más altos
que los anteriores
altos
pero ya cuando tomamos
esa decisión
ya cuando tomamos
esta operación
ya no podemos decir
que vamos a cerrar
manual
o que
no
ya está
tomada
la decisión
muchachos
y ya tenemos
que dejar
que el mercado
haga lo suyo
listo
eso fue todo
muchachos
como les pareció
o como les ha parecido
cristian
el mercado
normalmente se comporta
así
o eso
digamos que también
tiene que ver
con algo de suerte
no
eso no
nunca
o sea
usted acá
usted tiene que
olvidar de la suerte
usted acá va a sacar
un análisis
va a sacar
una estrategia
nosotros le vamos a enseñar
diferentes maneras
de operar
y usted va a colocar
su posición
porque muy probablemente
acá
nos hubiera
podido sacar
por stock
donde no hubiera
respetado
esa resistencia
que teníamos
en alta temporalidad
y se devuelve
al mercado
y ahí no tiene que ver
absolutamente
nada
la suerte
¿por qué?
porque
ustedes tienen que entender
de una vez
que un profit
o un stop
para un trader
profesional
que es en lo que
ustedes tienen que
convertirse
no significa
absolutamente
nada
no es como si
perdieran un dedo
o como si
perdieran un familiar
perdieran
no
acá estamos
perdiendo
dinero
pero como lo perdemos
no lo podemos ganar
entonces no se trata
de suerte
se trata de sacar
un análisis
una estrategia
perfeccionarla
a su gusto
y ejecutarla
ahora
si nos vamos
a enloquecer
a entrar
y a salir
las veces
que nosotros
queramos
pues a
descapitalizar
una cuenta
obviamente
pues
si salió positivo
eso sí
tiene que ser
algo muy de bueno
pero si usted
lo hace
conscientemente
correctamente
profesionalmente
usted
deja que el mercado
fluya
y que el mercado
cumpla lo suyo
miren que ahí
salimos por profit
pero hubiéramos
podido salir
también por stop
no pasa nada
es un análisis
que sacamos
sobre un
techo
que se convirtió
en piso
y acá
nos estaba
confirmando
y nos dio
el profit
pero si se hubiera
devuelto
esa posición
que yo hubiera
colocado ahí
con ese valor
era muy válida
para mi
para mi plan
perderla
hace parte
de ese plan
perderla
una cosa muy
diferente
es que yo me
sobreapalanqué
tan fuerte
que quiera
ganar mucho
y a la final
salgo perdiendo
listo
entonces
no se trata
de suerte
se trata
de
una pregunta
o sea
que la decisión
de entrar
en compra
es por el análisis
de las resistencias
que se hicieron
en el mercado
exactamente
esa fue
una de las entradas
que nosotros hicimos
también
en el
en el grupo
que yo tengo
de avanzados
donde
esa entrada
la hicimos
y nos tocó
esperar mucho
mucho
desde las
desde las once
de la mañana
prácticamente
hasta la
una y media
que salimos
pero porque
ya habíamos
colocado
la posición
listo
muchachos
como están
haciendo ustedes
la dinámica
o sea
el curso
está diseñado
para que ustedes
en el grupo
que se creó
de whatsapp
coloquen
la posición
manden la foto
y expliquen
por qué entran
ya sea que
salgan por
stop
o por profit
si lo están
haciendo
lo hicieron
con Daniel
si
si nos explicó
la verdad
cristian
yo no lo he hecho
porque he tenido
muy poco tiempo
mis actividades
laborales
no me han dejado
pero él
si nos explicó
listo
entonces
para los que puedan
los que puedan
lo hacen
y nosotros
le hacemos
la retroalimentación
del mercado
todos los días
yo se la hago
toda la semana
listo
mañana
lo vamos a ver
paso por paso
hoy vimos
cómo entrar
en la estructura
de cista
mañana vamos a ver
cómo vamos a entrar
en la estructura
bajista
pero también
vamos a ver
cómo lo vamos a hacer
cuando hay un cambio
de tendencia
que es muy importante
también que lo vean
listo
no se preocupen
que yo sé
que es la primera
clase
esa primera clase
todos quedan
como embombados
porque es mucho
mucha cosa
pero a medida
que ustedes vayan
viendo los días
y siendo muy justos
van a entender
mucho más
conmigo
y la otra semana
con Marco
listos
listo
cristian
muchísimas gracias
muchachos
hablamos
mañana
a la misma
hora
siete y media
listo
ok
mañana nos vemos
muchas gracias